all right Victoria is with me in Kansas
City hi Victoria how are you hi Dave I'm
doing so well how are you
better than I deserve what's up okay so
my husband and I are currently on baby
set two and we have about $60,000 now so
just we're just getting started and all
along our plan has been to wait and
color out of debt to have kids to start
a family and so now I think that we're
kind of getting a little bit of hope and
a little bit of traction we're realizing
not emotionally we're ready and we want
to have children but we're wondering
like would it still be smarter to wait
until we paid up all of our debt on like
what is your stance on that or should we
just kind of start now and roll within
and maybe take a little longer to pay
off our debt but you know in 25 years of
doing this show I've never told someone
to not get married or not have kids
based on their debt I Paul is that you
do that when God tells you to do that
okay and but now we use common sense
with that mix okay in other words we
don't marry someone who's $400,000 in
debt and thinks they want to go another
$400,000 in debt if you hate debt that's
not going to be a good marriage it's
kind of a hell on earth so that's the
reason is not the debt the reason is the
person's attitude toward the debt in
that case well then the you know the
baby thing babies don't cost that much
it's just a disruption in terms of the
cash flow and so you're going to be fine
you're going to be surprised about how
much formula is and that you have a
federal law says you have to go to the
pediatrician 46 times and all that but
you know but that kind of stuff costs
but the rest of it they don't you know
they don't take up that much space they
don't burn any more electricity so okay
you know it's just you know how babies
when you ready to have babies now what I
would do if you're in baby step two when
you become pregnant not until but when
when the doctor says okay then I would
stop baby step two temporarily and build
up an emergency fund until baby comes
and then use that emergency fund to
reinstate and kick into baby step two
again after baby comes and mama comes
and everything comes home from hospital
everybody spine
restart again but you're temporarily
plays press pause on your desk snowball
if you're doing a pregnancy in the
middle of it this is the Dave Ramsey
show hey guys thanks for watching if you
enjoyed this video click the subscribe
button to get the latest content and
check out these other great clips from
the show
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
Oh
[Music]